- That was our band logo,
"The more you drink, the better we sound."
(film cast and crew laughing)
So here it's, "The more you
drink, the better we talk."
(upbeat exciting music)
- Hey, everyone.
My name is Ruben Garcia,
and I am so excited to welcome you
to this special conversation
celebrating "Father of the Bride."
Tonight, we'll be joined by
the incredibly talented cast
and creative team from the
film, to discuss the process
of bringing this modern rom-com to life.
It really is a perfect re-imagining
of a timeless classic,
with a cultural twist.
And it has something for everyone.
Family, music, food,
a little bit of drama,
and a whole lot of heart.
I really can't wait for
you all to check it out.
Before we jump into the conversation,
here is a quick look at the film.
- Poor guy.
- Poor guy?
Okay?
- I just feel sorry
for someone who has no choice
but to fight for money you know?
- Would you like me to change the channel?
- No, no, no.
This is your house, please-
- No, no, no-
No, (chuckles) What sport
would you prefer to watch?
- I don't really watch sports.
- You don't watch sports?
- No.
- Do you play sports?
- I like hiking.
- Hiking's not a sport.
Your father never taught you any sports?
He never took you to any games?
- No, he did, he has a soccer team,
and we had to go watch him play every week
until I got tired of it.
- Hello men!
(speaking in foreign language)
(light jazzy music)
- Adan, your parents will be
- A soccer team-
- Here soon, right?
- Yeah.
- I need to warm up the fricassee.
- Let me help you.
(Sofia speaking in foreign language)
- He got him right in the bun.
- Yeah.
- Welcome to Academy Panels.
My name is Shawn Finnie,
Executive Vice President,
and today I have the honor and privilege
of sitting down with the amazing cast
and filmmakers from the
"Father of the Bride."
Welcome, everybody!
- (in unison) Thank you Shawn!
- Y'all gotta make a little more noise.
Welcome, everybody!
(group cheering and clapping)
(Shawn laughing)
Honestly y'all, I'm so excited
to see this re-imagined story told
with such culture, such truth and honesty.
And it's really the documentation
of like the human story, right?
We all know how interesting
weddings can be,
we all know the drama it
brings out in families,
and all of the others,
and I just appreciate
the way that you all approached it.
And Gaz I want to start with you,
because I feel like we've seen
this timeless classic re-imagined before.
We had it in the '50s, we had
it re-imagined in the '90s,
and now it has such an interesting lens,
because I feel like it
represents the world
that we all live in, and
I'm just curious for you,
what brought you to this
film, and wanting to tell
this story specifically,
"Father of the Bride?"
- So,
when I read the script,
what clicked with me
is this
sense,
it's this instinct
that I'm an immigrant into this country,
and now, my daughter when
she's with her friends,
she comes in speaking
like a Valley girl saying,
(mimicking)
"Daddy?"
And I just go like, "What?"
I'm like, "Call me Papi or something,
"but don't do that," no?
And you kind of realize
that, we came to this country
looking for better opportunities,
but with that comes a certain tax of,
losing,
your traditions and culture,
and watching that fade into the U.S.,
into the American melting pot.
And, that was my way in.
And we spoke about that,
and everyone said, "That's a way in."
I spoke about this with Andy,
and Andy immediately
started to just say how much
this was also an issue for him.
So we teamed up around that as well.
And of course, Matt's script
had all of that texture
of Mexicans and Cubans coming together,
and it felt like it was
just gonna be a lot of fun
for the creators to agree on
what are the similarities,
and then what would the differences be,
being that we're the Mexicans.
Adria is like an emissary
of both countries, no?
And then you have the Cubans,
and like we all,
spend vacations in Miami.
So then Gloria and Andy
introduced us to their Miami.
And eventually, that was
how we built the movie.
And the fact that, I hoped that
was gonna be the experience,
and it was even better.
- I love that.
And I love that it's a
universal film, you know?
It's a universal film, a universal story
documenting again, the human experience.
Matt, coming to you.
I love that we also really
delve into the relationship,
and the gender kind of roles and changes
where we saw Adria's
character really propose,
which we don't often see.
So I'm curious from the
perspective of writing,
how important was it to be reflective of,
this new space that we're
in, talking about gender,
the roles, the generation
and traditional gaps there?
- Gaz and I always talked about, you know,
the Spencer Tracy version is very much
the "Father of the Bride" of it's time.
And the Steve Martin version
is very much the "Father
of the Bride" of it's time.
What is the "Father of
the Bride" of our time?
We knew we had this great immigrant story.
I've always been interested
in the fact that,
whether it was the mother of
the bride or the bride herself,
the previous films, as great as they are,
aren't hugely concerned
with their stories, right?
Elizabeth Taylor, in the
MGM version from the '50s,
she's all about picking the china,
and you know, that's kind of it.
And so we were really interested,
maybe because I have two daughters,
and you know, they're very independent,
I thought the "Father of the
Bride" of our time could,
while remaining true to that
father/daughter relationship
that is obviously at
the core of the movie,
we could get a first look
that the previous movies
were not concerned
about into the marriage,
of the parents of the bride,
and where are they in their relationship?
And in the case of the bride,
this incredibly strong
and independent woman
who,
is not going to just,
like Elizabeth Taylor,
as much as I love her in that movie,
is not gonna sit idly by while
her father calls the shots.
So that was hugely important.
Like, that felt like a
modern take that honored
what's great about "Father of the Bride"
and why people love that movie,
but yet felt of our time.
- I love that, and going to the parents,
you are playing two iconic roles.
First of all you're two iconic actors-
- No.
- Let's just give it up
to you all first.
- We're just humans-
- Iconic humans, who
happen to be iconic actors.
- I'm kind of new on the scene.
He's like, the actor
dude. (group laughing)
- What was it about when
Gaz brought it to you,
and you mentioned it a little bit before,
like what was it when he brought
this specific kind of idea
around "Father of the Bride" to you both,
that made you all really just
invested and interested in it?
- Well, the conceit of doing it
was a great privilege,
to be thought of like,
as Paul presented the idea,
"We're doing this thing based
"around a Cuban family, and I
wasn't supposed to tell you,
"but we're writing it for you."
You know, he told me that early on.
I said, "No, I," so I felt
it was a privilege to really,
to be considered, and I
was honored to jump in.
And then I read Matt's draft,
and immediately was taken by it,
And I felt,
not only a privilege,
but a responsibility,
to jump in to make sure that
I can contribute in getting it right.
Because a lot of times,
cultures are represented
in such stereotypical ways
from people who don't have
an insight really to it,
and, so that was something
that I felt important for me.
I guess at the core of it all,
there was a discovery that
we have this arc in the movie
that's unique to this film, and also,
that, as Matt said,
"The women in the piece
"are the driving force and the catalyst"
for this man to change
and to be able to move on
from the traditions he's grown up with
that are very important to
him, and they're very real.
You know, he's protecting it.
He's like a dog with a bone.
He will not let go, and the more pressure
you put on a character like that then,
the more humor, and
more fodder for comedy,
and also for pain, and some
emotional moments to surface.
I was all in from the get-go.
And then when Gaz came on
board, we started to spit-ball
about who are these people really?
Who are the actors we want?
Who is the Mexican family?
Because depending who they are,
they could be from Monterey,
they can be from Mexico
City, are they from Durango?
Are they a farmer?
Is he a rancher?
We knew he had to have a lot of money,
but how did he come about it?
'Cause depending on who it
is, you have to cast an actor
that has the persona of
that characterization,
the behavior.
- He's a flirt,
the father of the groom.
- The father is a flirt.
Yes, he's a Tulum flirt.
- Exactly. (group laughing)
And for me, it was a no-brainer.
I mean, I get a text from Andy
whose texts are short and sweet.
"I'm sending you a script."
Okay?
I know that he doesn't do that, you know,
without really believing in something.
So I'm thinking, what is it?
And when it arrives, it's
"Father of the Bride."
I'm going, "Oh my God!"
I was a fan, and I'm going,
"These are big shoes to fill.
"How is that gonna be?"
I read your script, I laughed out loud.
I mean, you and I share a lot
of the same sense of humor,
that I know we leaned into
more of the heartwarming
and making kind of fun of
ourselves and our culture,
but I love all those jokes
that you had in there,
and it drew me in, and then, Gaz,
I find out he's directing,
and he wanted to talk to me.
And I said, "Okay, am I gonna
read for this, sort of?"
He says, "No, we want you for the role."
I go, "Damn, they're gonna
trust me?" (group laughing)
This is my first leading role,
And I had watched (speaking
in foreign language)
maybe like a month before
you reached out, and I fell
in love with that film so much
that I looked for, who is this?
How did they do this?
It was such a beautiful film,
and funny, but heartwarming.
So I was all in from the
get-go, and I thought,
my God, what a great
opportunity, you know?
I've waited a long time.
They've sent me scripts
through the years that I go,
"You know, mm," I carry a lot of baggage
from my musical career, and
it's a responsibility to me.
I don't want to disappoint,
either my fans or my culture,
and I've always chosen things that,
like I was saying to
you, elevate the culture,
or advance me as an actor, you know?
So, those things hadn't arrived,
but when this came, it was like ooh-hoo!
I moved my whole schedule around,
(group laughing)
so that I could do it!
Because I was really busy,
and I said, "Oh my God, I
can't let this slide by."
And it was such a great experience.
We had such a good time.
- You know,
both of your individual
contributions to the film,
amazing job by the way.
- Oh, thank you.
- But I'm just curious, talk to me about
the dynamic of your roles together,
and the intersection of like the family,
bringing Diego's character to the family,
and just your experience
of those two characters coming together.
- I feel like this is when
we lie and tell everyone
we're method actors or
something. (group laughing)
- Honestly, it was probably
one of the easiest things
about this film was
discovering our dynamic.
We knew each other from before,
and, we just had like
an instant connection.
I just trusted him.
Sort of the second I
met him we had a dinner
that lasted like about
four and a half hours.
And we talked about
everything but the movie.
- Yeah.
- We talked about our lives,
we talked about our secrets,
and we really had just, the best time.
And I respect him as an
actor, he respects me,
and since day one, I think,
I knew that I trusted him
and that I was in really good hands.
It allowed me to sort of just
really settle into Sofie.
And then, discovering
those little differences
between how Sofie was sort of brought up
and how Adan was brought
up, I think there was a lot
in conversations that I had
with Gaz and with you as well,
of like, Gaz asked me a
really important question,
which was, "What do you see in a man?"
Like, what are the qualities in a man
that attract you to someone?
And that was an interesting
question from him, and I go,
"Well, I want someone that
listens and that supports me."
And, then we started building that
into the beginning of the monologue,
and it's the reason for that question
that Gaz smartly asked, and was like,
"Those are the qualities
that someone like Sofie,
"a modern woman, should look like."
Sort of like depicting,
or killing the stereotype
of the prince charming
and really making like,
"Hey, this is the new prince charming."
It's someone who supports
you, that lets you fly,
that allows you to have space,
that sees you as an equal
and doesn't see himself superior
to you or like a housewife.
Really sees you as an intellectual,
and as a career woman.
And that's what sort of, we really,
loved, because that's
who Sofie would, marry.
And I think that was so
easy for us to discover.
I mean, I think Diego is probably,
one of the biggest
gentlemen I've ever met.
- Nah-
- So it was so,
it was just like, even off set I was like,
"You're such an Adan in so many ways."
(group laughing)
He really is!
- Yeah, my wife feels the same way!
(group laughing)
- Well, there's only two types of casting,
typecasting and miscasting.
- Exactly. (group laughing)
- But I love that because, and
Diego I'm gonna come to you,
but in the scene where
she's talking about,
when Andy your character
is talking to him,
and you all are having that conversation,
and you realize that the move to Mexico,
you're really following her.
- Yes!
- And when initially, you thought that
she was following him, and
so diving into that aspect
of how supportive he is, and
his character is as a husband,
like that he's willing to maneuver
and move his whole life to be around you,
which is reflective of that modern day,
which is reflective of this
new time that we're in,
which allows this new story
to kinda have a lot more breadth.
But Diego, I wanna come to you
from just your perspective
of your character,
and how it intersects with Adria.
- I was honored when Gaz
reached out at first,
and I was very excited 'cause I came from
doing a project where
the character I played
was completely different to Adan.
And, after I read the
script and I understood,
you know, how important it was for Adan
to be completely different to Billy,
and to really contrast that,
and have it be more like
the modern guy who's you know,
supportive of his fiance,
who's willing to change,
and adapt to her life,
and I love that 'cause it
changes that stereotype.
And then immediately after, I
was like, "Adria, let's talk."
- Mm-hmm.
- You know?
And we would just, we
spent hours on the phone
just discussing, going over scenes,
talking about the character, but also,
mainly I just wanted us
to get to know each other
so that that chemistry showed, on screen.
You know, like Adria said, we
went out to dinner in Atlanta.
- You took her to yoga,
camping, and surfing.
- Exactly.
(group laughing)
Exactly, (laughs) exactly!
We just hit it off, and you
know, once we were on set,
it was a piece of cake.
So being able to work that
with Gaz, and talk about
the character with him,
and understand those differences,
and those subtleties that would
make Adan contrast to Billy,
and working with Adria together,
and getting that chemistry,
and just feeling comfortable
and trusting each other
was what was really special about this.
- And we saw your character
really kind of inspire
in your character, this
idea of vulnerability,
in understanding what's
happening in your stories, right?
'Cause it's about the bride,
but it was about the family.
It was about the other
daughter, it was about
all the different elements.
- Everybody, yeah.
- So you're watching
the human story unfold,
but you're watching your marriage
kind of like get on the rocks,
and then we're watching you kind of really
be able to inspire in him this idea.
- To a certain degree I think
that Matt can relate to this.
You're chasing certain concepts,
and as you're going into production,
they start to come into focus
when, now you know who your cast is, no?
And during the small conversations
as you're building it out
and interviewing everyone,
information starts to come through
that suddenly create new
layers of specificity,
where abstract thoughts
start to become particular.
So, Adria's story when we were speaking
the first time about the movie,
she just tells me the story
of how she tells her dad
that she's engaged, and
the dad was like, "Okay."
And suddenly, he disappears,
and they're living in Miami,
and,
they call Adria up, and they're like,
"Your dad is in New York."
And,
why?
And she calls, "Dad, what are you doing?"
He's like, "I don't know, I
just felt like seeing a play."
(group laughing)
- Wow!
- And I was like,
"That's amazing," and just the stories
that she kept saying
on how on her wedding,
it was almost as if she had
to take care of her dad.
I was like,
"That is particular information
"that just makes the movie real."
- Yeah.
- You know?
And it's all of those
conversations with Diego
that suddenly he was just talking about,
like where he was struggling
in understanding the character
and how these ideas could
actually come together,
that, it turns out that
Diego has been married
more to the character
that he has been playing
for all these seasons,
and it turns out that
Diego played more himself
in this movie, than in other characters.
He's like this really
good-natured, sweet guy,
that he just dared to
show that side of himself.
So it was just those sort of things
that started to inform the characters,
and it just made the movie more
intimate for all of us, no?
I mean, Andy, I'm sure you have things
that you can't talk about (laughs) now,
aren't you marrying like
two daughters right now?
- Yeah, two weddings in 30 days.
- Two weddings in 30 days?
- "Father of the Bride" is a
documentary, (group laughing)
there are not too many facts about Andy!
- And a press tour in the middle.
That's crazy.
- Light work.
- By the way, I really need to say,
last night when we watched it,
I watched it for the first
time on the big screen,
so many things came to life that,
you,
even in a simple line,
which got a huge laugh,
"Do you have tea?"
It's like, in every single little line,
you brought this,
personality and this person
to life even more.
People were cracking up over it because,
you know immediately like here he is,
Mr. Espresso man, whipping
it up like you know,
he's so proud of making the Cuban coffee.
And you just went, "Do you have tea?"
And, oh my gosh.
- But also,
it's all informed from
the script, you know,
before he says, "Do you have tea?"
He's already said, "I've been proposed to,
"and I like yoga, camping, and surfing."
So it's all like beats
that continue to create.
It's like yet another thing for Billy
to go, "You don't like sports?"
"I like hiking."
"Hiking's not a sport."
(group laughing)
- And then he asks like,
"Did you play any sports?"
He's like, "Not at all."
(group laughing)
You're like, "Interesting."
I mean, it is the modern world
- We'll change the channel,
what do you wanna watch?
- Yeah!
- The modern woman with the modern man.
- The Food Network?
- Yeah!
- Can we put on the Food Network?
(group laughing)
- HGTV?
- What do you want individuals
to take away from this film?
- There's a certain hope that
I feel this film promises,
where, generations are divided,
global views are divided, and yet,
they live under the same household, no?
So,
I kinda want,
there's a bit of a utopic thinking
about what the idyllic
family can look like,
coming together in spite
of their differences.
I also think that,
a lot of media right now is
trying to portray the most
progressive versions of life,
and I wanted to for a second,
portray, the people that are like,
second or third wave behind the progress.
Just sort of saying like, "Yeah, I agree,
"I'm just, let me catch up," you know?
And speak to the middle of the country
that is not polarized,
they're just sort of trying
to figure out where the new voices are.
And just speak to the families
where all that conflict
is happening, and just say, "You know,
"it's a generational thing,
It's happening everywhere.
"Hang in there, it'll be fine.
"We all want to be together,
"and we can break bread
at the end," you know?
That's my hope at least for the movie.
- Which is why it's a universal
film documenting humanity.
- Yeah.
- Right?
And documenting family, and documenting
the intersections of all of them
with this daughter,
with the other daughter.
Adria, I'm curious for you.
What do you want people
to take from the film?
- There's so many things I want people,
I think, to take out of this movie.
I think Gaz said it really beautifully.
I think this movie, like you just said,
is incredibly universal,
and I'm excited for people
to see two cultures,
two Latin American cultures come together,
and to finally see the
differences, and to not,
we've always sort have
been put in one box,
and I mean, I've been told multiple times
that Puerto Rico's in
Mexico or in Argentina.
And, or like I'm Puerto
Rican, that means I'm Mexican.
And it doesn't, and I think this film
is gonna show those differences,
and also show the world
that we're just like everybody else.
I think for the first time
in a really long time,
we've sort of all taken the reigns
and we haven't been stereotyped.
And we've taken the reigns
of our narrative yet again,
and we're like, "Hey, guys,
this is actually who we are."
And it's funny and it's
warm, but at the same time,
we're just exactly like you.
We just maybe listen to different music,
and maybe eat different food,
and maybe dance a little different.
At the same time, we're all
in this human experience.
So, I want people to take away that.
To sort of see us, and see us for sort of
who we are, and just really enjoy
and have a good time watching this film.
We had a blast making this.
We had the best time,
and I think it's probably
the best filming experience I've ever had,
and I think I will ever have,
because I have fallen in love
with every single
human
on this
film,
like genuinely.
And us actors, I mean, let's
be all really honest right now,
We lie all the time.
(group laughing)
We lie all the time!
There hasn't been a press
tour that I have said,
I'm like, "I love these people."
I'm lying.
- Yeah.
- I love these people.
- How do we know you're not lying?
(group laughing)
- No, no, because
I text you, I hug you, like, you know
how much I love you.
- We still talk-
- Yeah, we still talk,
we have a group-
- We still hang out-
- We have a group chat, I feel comfortable
with these people, these are like
my secondary family-
- You have a group chat?
- (group laughing) You
tried to FaceTime us
the other day on that group chat,
what are you talking about?
You're like, "Let's FaceTime."
And Gloria was like, "Which one of us?"
(group laughing)
Which one of us in this?
We're like 15 people in this chat!
I think we had a blast, and I think,
I just want people to have the best time.
I think this movie could not
have come at a better time.
I think the world's crazy out there,
and I think this movie will allow people
to sort of escape, and have fun,
while also being taught a
couple lessons along the way.
'Cause it's so funny, I
think they're gonna see
what Gaz was talking about in a funny way
and without realizing just how much
they're sort of learning
about the dynamics
in their family, or the generational gaps,
or even the gender roles
in their own family.
I'm really excited for my grandparents,
and my, well, my grandfather
from my mom's side
and my father to watch this movie.
You know, I think it'll be great.
(Shawn laughs)
I think it'll be really fun!
- I love that, I love that.
And Matt, Diego, and Gloria, and Andy,
I wanna ask you all a separate question.
You kind of alluded to it earlier.
How impactful is that experience?
That we haven't been in the theater
for a long time due to COVID,
and so many changes in our
world that we've known?
How important and how impactful is it
to still see it on the theater?
You mentioned like-
- Oh, gosh-
- When you you saw it in the theater,
and you saw everybody responding
to the laughs-
- Yes!
- Opening it up to you all,
to kind of weigh in-
- It was so special for me,
because that's the reason
that we go to movies,
to have a collective experience.
And I know, we've all learned how
to have a collective experience
individually in our homes.
People have watch parties
through apps and things,
because we still crave that.
I love the fact that everything's
accessible from home,
because who knows, how long
we're gonna be in and out
of this situation, but
there's nothing like
seeing bigger than life characters,
literally bigger than life.
On a screen you see so many subtleties,
that you'll never catch
on a smaller screen.
And it's just being together
which is what I hope,
this film does-
- You don't pick up-
- Like families-
- Your phone,
you don't pick up your phone-
- Right.
- When you're watching-
- Oh, wait a minute,
let me text somebody while I'm doing this.
Or me, let me play
Candy Crush.
- Can you rewind?
(group laughing)
- There's no pause!
- Also laugh is so contagious.
- Yeah.
- Like someone laughs
and it just makes you wanna,
it's such an empathetic
experience to go to the cinema.
Like you said, you wouldn't
pull out your phone
because you're concerned,
that you might ruin
someone else's experience
by shining your light.
Or like, if someone you know next to you
is sort of feeling that moment,
you're like, "Oh, wait."
It becomes like this empathetic
group experience.
- Or when someone belly laughs
at something totally unexpected,
then you're going, "Wait a minute."
- What did I miss?
- What is going on there?
It's just beautiful, together, you know?
- Or cries, and you go, "Are
you crying?" (Gloria laughs)
- Matt and Diego, I'm curious from you all
about that theatrical experience.
Being in it, and seeing
it on the big screen.
- I mean, man, seeing it
yesterday with an audience
was amazing, 'cause you
could really see, and hear,
like, and be with the audience
as they were laughing,
as they were gasping, as they were crying.
You know, I saw it with
my mom, and my mom was,
the third act in she was just
crying and then laughing,
and you know, there's
really nothing like it.
There's nothing like it,
it was amazing to be able
to be in the theater
yesterday and see how excited,
and how in it the audience
members were, you know?
It was great.
- And those are the reactions,
'cause whenever I do a
concert, I know immediately
how that audience is
responding 'cause I'm there.
- Yeah.
- But actors do their craft
and hope for the best.
And hope that what they do has translated
to the point where it's gonna move people.
And in the theater is
where you see it happen.
- You sort of get instant gratification.
- Yes, you don't see it in people's homes,
they're all doing their thing, you know?
But it's an amazing, oh, my God, it was
so special for me.
- Matt for you, I am curious.
- Completely concur.
I've probably seen the
film five or six times.
That was the first time in
front of a live audience.
And, there's just an energy to it,
and people grabbing me
after, like, who were,
you can't judge a book by its cover.
These were not Latino people,
who were just like, "I cried
three times during that movie,
"and I didn't expect it."
And how often I heard a version
at the party after the screening,
how often I heard a version of like,
"We need this movie.
"We need this movie right now."
And another thing I heard was like,
and it was almost evenly split,
"I can't wait to show my kids,"
and then, "I can't wait
to show my parents,"
which I think speaks
to, you used the word,
universality of this.
It's a film that I think,
works because, at the same time
there's a great specificity
to the humor, and you hit on it.
It's getting better, but many depictions
in film and television of Latinos,
it's frequently we're a monolith,
we're a uni culture, and we're not.
And years ago, you know, I was
an executive at DreamWorks.
I had a whole other career,
and they gave us lunch downstairs.
And my assistant came
up one day and she said,
she didn't mean anything by it,
she's like, "Oh, they have
your people's food downstairs."
And I thought to myself,
if I go down there
and there's papa rellena,
I'm gonna be shocked.
So I go down there, and it was,
here's the punchline, it was tostada bar.
I was like, "Okay, she
thought it was Mexican food."
By the way, that's American food.
- Yeah, exactly.
- Yeah.
- Yes.
- You know?
And we wanted to,
on the hand, celebrate the differences
between these cultures, but
what I love about the movie,
and especially the end
is, at the end of the day
there are these commonalities though.
There are these common
denominators of family,
of food, of music, of closeness,
that transcend culture.
And, you can be an immigrant from Cuba,
or you can be an immigrant from Senegal,
and, you know what that is,
to on the one hand, you come to America
and there's this beautiful
assimilation that takes place,
but there's a cost to the assimilation.
And that tension of like how do we hold on
to these things that are so dear,
and are so part of who we are,
but at the same time
join this melting pot?
And seeing the audience validate that
was just really exciting.
- Yeah.
- That was beautifully put.
Before I wrap this conversation,
'cause I heard you talking
about it a little bit earlier,
I have to ask, what is the scene,
that didn't make it into
the film, (Matt laughs)
that you all thought would make,
God, that was an amazing scene!
Or you just had fun filming it.
- So many.
- The wedding was amazing.
I mean we had so much fun-
- But that's in the movie-
- Shooting that wedding-
- But what was-
- Like what's the scene
that wasn't in there?
You said you went through different edits.
- No, everything we wanted stayed there.
- Everything is is in there-
- Everything we wanted-
- There's one scene between me and Gloria,
where I said, "I've tried my best."
- Yeah.
- And she said,
"I know you have, Billy,"
and she gives me a kiss.
It was early when we
put the kids to sleep,
After we're in bed together.
- Yeah-
- But I understood why they don't-
- No, yeah-
- Wanna pay off-
- it was too soon-
You saw there were gonna get-
- Putting us back
together early.
- Yeah.
- It was leaning-
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, it was-
- Structurally it was off, you know?
- It was just lines that I missed, jokes,
and by the way, it was Ruben Rabasa-
- Acapulco-
- Who steals every scene.
- That is the one!
- Acapulco is the one-
- Acapulco is the one!
- That dinner table scene
which we shot for two days,
we couldn't get through, some
of the lines because he was,
thankfully you let us,
you gave us the blessing
of being able to you know,
improvise and do fun stuff.
But Ruben Rabasa, oh my God, it was like,
we were just cracking up for
this stuff he would throw out.
And Chloe.
- Yeah, and Chloe-
- Chloe and Casey?
- And Casey!
- They would go off,
and Gaz would say, "Just go."
Their improvisations,
were so insane.
I missed that her she-boss didn't make it.
- I saved her-
- You saved her.
- We kept it for Andy.
- You kept it for Andy,
and people cracked up when you said it!
Because it was so out
of character (laughs)
for you to say the she-boss.
But some of the stuff
that they came up with,
oh my Lord!
- She has a video.
- Yeah, I have a video of that scene
where Ruben said "Acapulco,"
and the entire
set, fell apart.
When I say fell apart,
I mean the camera guy
was like, "I can't even
hold this camera anymore."
Dying laughing, Gaz came
in like, dying laughing,
but also like, "Guys, we gotta film."
And then the more he heard us laugh,
the more he was laughing, and he was like,
"I can't stop this," and
Andy, and I'm laughing,
and you hear me and Andy
is just cracking up,
and he can't even breathe.
- I was crying.
- He was crying, he was like cleaning up,
and then he kept putting
a napkin on his head,
like just giving up on life.
It was so funny,
I have a video-
- How did you,
you had a camera and you
started to videotape me?
- Yeah, I just started
filming you! (laughing)
- I was like-
- I was off camera,
I wasn't on camera!
- Oh, that was-
- It was a reaction to, probably Acapulco!
- Because it was like the
third time that happened.
Like we would finish the scene,
and then it would be like,
or like, we're about to
finish the scene, Acapulco!
And he would die!
Second time.
Third time, we were like, "You guys,
"we need a 20-minute laugh break,
because we can't!"
- That's the one line
I regretted in the movie-
- He was reminiscing,
about an Acapulco experience-
- Acapulco-
- And when we're talking about,
her taking off to Mexico-
- Director's cut.
- After this whole speech, that is like,
I don't even know how long,
and then all of a sudden,
I say, "I'm going to Mexico,"
and he goes, "Oooh, Acapulco!"
I mean, and just the way he
said it, it was so funny.
And I also have a picture-
- Lewd and lascivious,
as I was saying-
- I have a picture of you
that day that you were
playing with your food,
and it's the cutest picture.
You made a smiley face with
your frijoles! (laughs)
- Okay, so I need to see this video
after we're done wrapping.
- Yes, yes!
- And I need to see that with her frijoles
in there.
- Oh my God!
- And we need a director's cut, clearly.
- We need the Acapulco scene-
- We need the Acapulco scene!
- Yes!
- But honestly, as a consumer,
and as somebody who wasn't
on set, those laughs,
the heart, the feeling, the
intentionality of like, family,
the perceived division that became unity
towards the end, beautiful!
I appreciated it, and
thank you all so much.
- And she said it, "Actors may lie,
"but you can't fake real."
- Yeah.
- And that energy gets on the project.
- Yeah-
- Whether it's music, or-
- So, I was not on their set.
Ironically enough, I was 10 miles away
on the set of a television show
that I created and was producing.
And, it was mostly a Latino
cast, Latino filmmakers,
and we called ourselves, La Familia.
And it was real.
It was that instant, like
from the moment we met.
And, I met most of you, really last night,
for the very first time,
and I was around you
for five minutes, and I
was like, that's a Familia.
I was like, I understand this, I know it,
it was very heartwarming to see.
And so as a latecomer to the party,
(chuckles) thank you guys
for being so welcoming-
- Welcome to the party!
(group laughing and clapping)
- But Gloria, you said it, it cannot be,
and what's amazing is, it's on the screen.
- Yeah!
- You see it.
It's a cohesiveness, it's a family thing,
and I'm not surprised that you created it.
Knowing you, I was like,
"Oh, good on them."
Like, that made me so happy.
- Well,
I mean the thing is that
we were all in Atlanta,
for eight weeks.
We didn't have a real in-point
to Atlanta when we got there,
and everyone had girlfriends,
husbands, wife and kids,
family-
- Daughter
and grandkids-
- Daughter, grandkids,
like, when we were not shooting,
when anyone was not shooting,
they were hanging out, no?
And then, Enrique Murciano
threw a party in his house,
the guy who plays Junior,
for his birthday, Saturday,
and Diego brings a friend that cooks like
the best burgers in
Mexico, (Matt laughing)
and we're just dancing
like until 3:00 a.m.
- And I made my cosmos-
- See, and-
- It's very good!
- She made her cosmos, no?
- I brought some Inca balloons-
- Then some night Adria
takes us all out bowling,
and Diego starts singing "Journey"
in the bowling alley. (Adria laughs)
- And we were dancing with
that band that was there-
- And that the wrap party that Gloria
threw at the house-
- Yes, oh, at the house,
in Miami!
- Oh, my God, were you-
- Yeah, she invited the entire
crew, everyone was there.
I mean, no one does that, really, I mean,
that party was legendary.
- That was a big party.
- Legendary!
- I found,
lots of interesting things in my house.
(group laughing)
After that party!
Some people called to ask for
them, and some people didn't!
(group laughing and clapping)
Just left it!
- We're gonna get that
definitely in the next interview,
but thank you for watching Academy Panels,
my name is Shawn Finnie,
and make sure you go and check
out "Father of the Bride".
(upbeat exciting music)